[Music]
you guys had an amazing moment Johnny at
the end of or there was a big parade and
you laid the trophy down at the marathon
finish line which I think we have a
picture of and this was an incredible
moment you know it meant a lot
nationally but particularly for the
people of Boston who who who went
through all that they went through last
spring let me tell you something that
that you know Marathon Monday I mean
that was something I've never been a
part of
we obviously have you know debts and
your family death here and you know
something you know tragedy like that an
explosive a bomb something so selfish an
act not only to Boston but on America
and and then we're supposed to be the
strong legs strong back to carry you
know everyone and put smiles on
everyone's faces well I got saying I
think it was the other way around I
think we jumped on Boston's back I mean
they wouldn't let us quit you know they
wouldn't let us you know lay it down I
mean obviously it happened right on the
finish line so you know you would think
in your head let's not go to the
baseball game you know because something
bad might happen there to know even more
people came through a Boston strong on
the Green Monster and we just rolled so
if everyone in Boston you know could get
a ring they deserve one too well
[Applause]